[Music]
have you noticed we've been breaking a
lot of records lately when it comes to
dangerous weather i bet you have ida is
one of the strongest hurricanes ever to
hit louisiana but we've had a number of
storms lately that were have been
described rather as a once in a
generation jeff berry dulle is our cbs
news meteorologist and climate
specialist i know you have noticed i'm a
specialist i've been busy yeah what is
happening here there's more energy in
the system whenever you have more energy
in the system you're adding more heat
for everything you know for fires in the
west you evaporate more moisture the
ground gets drier we we're having our
worst drought in 1200 years in the west
um in the east and the gulf of mexico
water temperatures are warmest so
specifically with ida ida moved over
some of the warmest water in the gulf of
mexico which has been made warmer by
climate change in fact atlantic ocean
temperatures are about two degrees
warmer warmer than they used to be now
what does warmer weather mean when you
have warmer weather that translates to
what well there's more energy for storms
to feed off of so really for every one
degree or two degree increase fahrenheit
uh in water temperature you see a 20
mile an hour increase in the intensity
of a storm that's tremendous so we're
looking at these surface temperatures i
mean 88 to 90 degrees is really bathtub
temperature it is so first it moved over
ocean heat content the loop current in
the gulf mexico then it moved over
surface waters that were 88 to 90
degrees so yeah this is high octane fuel
it's like putting steroids
into a storm the storm is still going to
happen it rapidly intensified in fact
rapid intensification has increased five
miles an hour per decade for the past
four decades and now it is two times
more likely that a hurricane will jump
from a run-of-the-mill hurricane to a
major cat three cat four cat5 two times
more likely now
in the atlantic ocean because primarily
of climate change and a warmer climate
it's almost a vicious cycle too because
as it ramps up energy in one place it
does something else someplace else some
places get drier some places get wetter
the rich get richer the poor get poorer
so if you're dry you get drier if you're
wet you get wetter and you know oh by
the way i have a question for you so
comparing a storm 75 miles an hour to
150 miles an hour how much more damage
potential do you think there is don't
say double 200 times you you saw the
graphic there must have been 250 times
more 250 times more damage potential
you're a genius how did you know
she's a genius
because i know i
i live with hurricanes i mean you know
when you live in the gulf it's
you keep your eyes open so that's why a
couple of degrees really really matters
and remember the most vulnerable people
the ones that are suffering the most and
they contribute the least to climate
change i just know when you're in the
building that means something that means
that that means the grim reaper is here
normally it's not something good but
we're always glad to see you because
you've got great